le soir du 21 septembre 93 lorsque les
enquêteurs investi cette bastide ils
savent qu'il n'ya plus lieu d'espérer au
fond d'un puits le corps de la petite
karine wolker disparu des preneurs
violet pardon assassiné son meurtrier
tout juste un terme il est passé aux
aveux patrick lissiers un multi
récidiviste était devenu un ami de la
famille dans l'après-midi du 13
septembre il va chercher karine à
l'école elle n'en reviendra jamais
tissier expliquera son geste par une
pulsion une envie subite de violer au
début je rêvais pas croire que c'était
lui qui avait pris karine j'ai toujours
douté j'ai dit non c'est pas possible
notre forêt tu es gentil glow toujours
chaud avec les enfants milo il a
toujours été correct je suis dit non
c'est pas lui c'est pas possible il a
même pas de peine il a même pas de
chacun
pour lui c'était comme s'ils avaient
fait quelque chose comme un gamin qui
avait cassé un jouet
on n'arrive pas comprendre ça on ne peut
pas imaginer qu'un être humain est
normal et puisse faire une chose
pareille
la maman de karine ne connaissait alors
ni le passé ni la dangerosité de l'homme
qu'elle côtoyait déjà condamné deux fois
pour meurtre et pour viol qui sied tout
juste sorti de prison savait se rendre
aimable
marie-josée goze porte encore les
lourdes séquelles de sa rencontre avec
tissier elle est l'une des rares
rescapées de sa folie meurtrière
elle aussi était en toute confiance
jusqu'au 10 septembre à 93 on a un
moment donné et s'approche de moi puis
me tais
j'ai envie de coucher avec toi et c'est
parti comme ça c'est comme si je vivais
encore je le raconte je le vis et tous
les jours cheville et à rien et rien qui
m'a échappé c'est quelque chose qui
marque qui est ancré dans ma tête je
n'ai que ça dans nos têtes
étrangler estropiés marie-josée go a
frôlé la mort mais elle tient
aujourd'hui affronter son agresseur dans
le box tissier qui quelques jours
auparavant avait également violé et tué
conchita l'ema sa voisine de palier de
meurtre et une tentative en un mois pour
les psychiatres il n'aurait aucun remord
et serait incurable tissier lui rétorque
qui n'a jamais été ni aidé ni suivi
pendant ou après la prison ce sont ces
crimes et son parcours qui ont inspiré
une nouvelle loi la perpétuité réelle
pour les violeurs et meurtriers
d'enfants